皆さん。ゴールデンウィークどうお過ごしでしょうか？
去年もやったんですけども、
ゴールデンウィークは、僕はなぜか、こう
一人で、ふらっと旅をするという動画を去年も出したので
今年もちょっとそういうテンションで
僕もゴールデンウイークを満喫したいわけですよ。
ゴールデンウイークを満喫したいわけなので
ちょっと今から「ふらっと」ちょっと外に出て
静岡で一人旅をしてこようと思います
多分ね去年から見ている人なら
わかると思うんですけども
特に面白くないんですけど
ただ僕がね、ふらっ…
（せき込み）
（鼻をかむ）
本当ただ僕がふらっと旅するだけなんで
たまにはこうね、安らぎのね
スピンオフ動画も撮ろうと思いまして
じゃ、早速…
行ってくるよ
本当、普通に外出て散歩するだけだから
じゃ、行ってきます
いや、マジそれだけだから
（スロットルを回す）
今から行く「久能山」っていう山があるんですけども
その山に一緒に登ることになりました！
（拍手）
めっちゃ助かります！
もう2人だと多分全然緊張もせずにガンガン登れるんで
ちょっと登っていきましょう！
ちなみに久能山、あちらです。
>>あ、じゃあかなり久々…？
>>けっこう久々です！
（笑い）
ダメだ恥ずかしいよ…助けて…
やめとこう、ちょっと、恥ずかしくなっちゃった
はい、というわけで
久能山の近くに着きました
あぁヤバい…人目が…
人目がメンタルに…
はい、というわけで久能山の近くに着きました
入口はこんな感じです
久能山東照宮っていうのは、
何か…
…歴史的な建物です…。
で何かこのね、ずっとね…あるんですけど
ここをずっと上っていく感じになります
じゃぁ上っていきましょう！
>>え、これ登ったことないですか？
>>ないです
>>いや、結構険しいですよ
足元悪いんですよね、結構
ここからずっと階段なんですけども
結構…キツい！
けど僕は今は1人じゃない！
後ろに…視聴者さんがついてる！
そして、この動画を見てる君たちもまた…
ついてきてる！
そう！
俺は…
1人じゃ
（ポンっ）
>>いや、同い年ぐらいかと思った
>>あ、本当ですか？
こんな感じでずっと歩いてきます
よし…
うわ、これやば…
こっから全部だよ、ここ…
（息を吐く）
>>どうだ…
>>結構見られるだろ… >>(笑い)
はい…
上ります！！
（息があがっている）
吐きそう…
病み上がりなんですよ…
おっ！
もう少しでゴールです。
きたー！！
伝わるだろ…この汗の量…！
これは伝わるよ、わかりますよね？…むっちゃかいてない？
ここから見る景色が多分いちばん綺麗です
はい、こんな感じでございます
静岡の海が
すごい
パノラマチックに見れるっていう
久能山の上はこんな感じになっております